úrsulafander Legend está en Madrid allí
ha sido recibida por el presidente del
gobierno español Pedro Sánchez quien
estrena la presidencia semestral
española de la unión juntos han
inaugurado la reunión entre el gobierno
del país y el colegio de comisarios
europeos en la agenda del encuentro
Ucrania ha ocupado un puesto prioritario
España ASUME la presidencia del Consejo
en un momento decisivo en el que debemos
redoblar nuestro apoyo a Ucrania
han pasado Ya 510 desde la brutal
invasión de Rusia
ambos mandatarios dejaron claro que el
bloque europeo no desistirá en su ayuda
a kiev en el Horizonte cercano está la
necesidad de un acuerdo para garantizar
la producción de munición
para que podamos entregar más munición a
Ucrania y al mismo tiempo reponer
también nuestras propias existencias Más
allá de Ucrania del presidente español
se centra en la respuesta europea la
migración una fuerte declaración de
intenciones luego del fracaso en el
último consejo europeo allí Polonia y
Hungría bloquearon un avance para un
pacto migratorio el desafío que
representa
la migración irregular
debe llevarnos a una respuesta común a
una respuesta europea trabajaremos desde
España para que ese acuerdo sea
equilibrado entre lo que representa la
responsabilidad y la solidaridad la
Unión Europea y su agencia de fronteras
frontex están en el punto de mira a
finales de junio naufragaron más de 700
migrantes cerca de las costas griegas
apenas un centenar sobrevivió días
después al menos 35 migrantes
desaparecieron frente a las costas
españolas de Canarias